what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and i
should add a little bit out of the mcu
since we talk about spider-man and the
sony spider-man universe a lot as well
and we do have a lot of news today
concerning the mcu and concerning the
sony verse because morbius has been
delayed i'm sure some of you have heard
this by now but there are some really
cool rumors going around right now about
possibly why it's been delayed and i'll
give you a hint about these rumors that
we're going to talk about it involves
andrew garfield so like i said pretty
crazy but pretty cool rumors we'll be
talking about and i have a theory that
i'll state in this video that i think a
lot of spider-man fans will really enjoy
so as usual lots to talk about and if
you love marvel and the mcu be sure to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest news now we'll talk about morbius
being delayed first and the crazy
theories going around it because i kind
of hyped it up in the beginning now
unfortunately we were only a couple of
weeks away from actually getting the
release of morbius but now it's been
delayed and moved back to april 1st and
no unfortunately it is not an april
fool's joke although very weird day to
pick a release now of course the reason
that sony states that they are moving
the movie back is because of the omicron
variant of kovid 19. now after speaking
with a few people over at sony during
the spider-man no way home premiere and
prior to that i have definitely
discovered that sony is taking a lot of
precautions when it comes to cover 19
which they should but they just released
spider-man no way home so one would
think that it should be relatively okay
for morbius now coveted cases are going
up which is probably their biggest
concern they don't want to contribute to
that with a worldwide movie premiere but
in the midst of all of this rescheduling
lies a very interesting opportunity and
this opportunity involves spider-man
particularly andrew garfield spider-man
now before we dive into this i want to
reiterate this is just a rumor this is
not confirmed by any means but it does
make sense and could be a massive
opportunity for sony the rumor right now
is that sony is pushing back morbius so
they can actually add andrew garfield
spider-man into the film and if you
consider a few things it actually makes
sense for them to do this and even if it
didn't i know everybody would want this
anyways now i should say that we are
about to talk about spiderman no way
home spoilers so if you haven't seen it
and somehow managed to avoid all the
spoilers on the internet this is your
warning but diving back into this after
spider-man knowing home released in
theaters and everybody got a chance to
see it or mostly everybody reports from
credible insiders like my time to shine
hello and daniel rpk have stated that
sony and marvel studios has plans for
andrew garfield and possibly toby
maguire most of the talk has been about
andrew garfield which is why this rumor
actually makes some sense if sony wants
andrew garfield to be sony's spider-man
in the spider-man universe that sony has
and they're planning on him appearing in
their universe in future films it would
make sense that they would take full
advantage of this opportunity of the
delay to somehow put andrew garfield in
the movie even if it's for just a quick
little cameo because if we think about
it this might have been sony's plan the
entire time to put andrew garfield in
this venom spider-man morbius black cat
craven the hunter big spider-man
universe that they have going on now let
me kind of state the fact that yes we
know tom holland spider-man is not done
but he's in the mcu and i think with all
of these other spider-man movies that
sony has planned and is releasing at
this point in time and has future
spider-man projects they're working on i
think it's very clear that there is
going to be a pretty big separation of
the universes after all that's why venom
got sent back at the end of spider-man
no way home so venom wasn't actually in
the mcu we could just get the symbiote
in the mcu and we can have that clear
division between universes so just
because angie garfield might be the
spider-man of the sony universe doesn't
mean tom holland is going anywhere and
now since basically anything is possible
with the multiverse we could see the
spider-man jumping in and out of
universes but let's look back to the
first morbius trailer and the main
morbius trailer the first one we saw
that picture of spider-man on the wall
with the word murderer over it now it
doesn't look like morbius is going to be
connecting to spider-man no way home in
any way we saw no mention of morbius in
no way home so in morbius's universe
there exists a spider-man and apparently
he is not liked by the public and
apparently people think he's a murderer
now this could just be clever trailer
editing that marvel is known to do even
though this is primarily a sony helmed
film it's still a possibility that that
might be clever editing however i
actually do think that there is a
spider-man in the morbius universe
because if you go to the second and main
trailer for morbius we can see the
oscorp building and the logo is exactly
the same as the logo from the amazing
spider-man universe if we combine these
two facts from these two different
trailers with the reports that sony
wants andrew garfield for future
projects it would make sense that sony
would take the opportunity with morbius
being delayed to add andrew garfield
into the film somehow that is if he
isn't already in it i have a theory
about this and i think people are going
to like it in spider-man no way home
where toby maguire and andrew garfield
first meet tom holland's peter parker on
top of the school roof they start
talking about loss peter starts talking
about losing aunt may and from here
andrew starts talking about losing gwen
and he tells us a little bit about how
his life was after that and here's the
really important part he says that he
stopped pulling his punches he got
bitter and for those of you who don't
know what that means let me explain
spider-man is super strong if he punches
a normal person he'll probably knock
that person out and maybe even kill them
but it'll definitely hurt them a lot so
basically what andrew garfield was
saying was i stopped holding back and i
was going full strength at people so he
got kind of violent now let's link this
to the picture that says murderer over
it what if spider-man got a little bit
out of hand andrew garfield spider-man
we already know from spider-man no way
home that he got a little bit out of
control he got violent and bitter
stopped holding back his punches perhaps
something happened here now i don't
think he killed anybody i want to make
that clear because that's not who peter
parker is even if he did lose gwen and
even if he was in a really dark space i
don't think that's something they could
say peter parker did but could he have
hurt some people yes and could some
unfortunate circumstances perhaps maybe
framed him to be a murderer yes that's
kind of what happens to spider-man he's
the hero but of course people like jjj
make him out to be a menace a villain so
what if this picture of spider-man which
we know is not tom holland spider-man
because it's a different suit turns out
to actually be andrew garfield
spider-man maybe this was their plan the
whole entire time knowing that andrew
was going to be in spider-man now a home
and knowing that he could have a future
in the sony universe after all before
they partnered with marvel studios that
was the plan they were going to make the
amazing spider-man 3. now i think
everything worked out the best way it
could and andrew finally got his
redemption in spider-man knowing home
and it looks like the future's bright
for him as spider-man and maybe sony
planned this the entire time for him to
come back into their own universe and to
be the main spider-man while tom holland
is in the mcu and maybe knowing that
they painted that picture of spider-man
in the morbius trailer knowing a
spider-man who was not tom holland was
going to be coming into their universe
very soon and then not to mention tom
hardy has talked a lot about the next
film for venom venom 3 being a
spider-man vs venom film well after
spider-man no way home's post-credit
scene they made it very clear that
there's going to be a different and new
venom in the mcu and it's not going to
be tom hardy's eddie brock but we're
still getting a third venom film that
takes place in the sony universe so
who's going to be the spider-man well it
looks like andrew garfield's going to be
and i'm really starting to think that
sony might actually have a master plan
behind everything that they've been
doing for the past few years or maybe
that's just wishful thinking on my part
but that's my theory let me know what
you all think about this in the comments
down below don't forget to like the
video and of course subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest mcu
news and theories and the sony spiderman
verse for live updates you can follow me
on instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof